"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
features some very high-profile deaths.
Whether it was a famous mutant or a superhuman
king who lives on the moon, here is every
superhero that died in "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness."
Not even Doctor Strange himself makes it out
alive of "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness."
Although it wasn't the Earth-616 version of
Stephen Strange who ultimately met his maker,
but several variants.
That said, the main universe's sorcerer must
be looking over his shoulder a lot more after
witnessing his Multiverse selves crumble before
his eyes.
Right at the start of "The Multiverse of Madness,"
a Strange variant bites the dust after a fight
with a demonic creature.
His body is then transported to Earth-616.
Eventually, his corpse ends up becoming a
reanimated zombie used to stop the Scarlet
Witch in the finale.
"I don't even wanna know!"
A flashback also showed how Earth-838's Strange
was obliterated by Black Bolt after becoming
too obsessed with the Darkhold.
Then, to solidify the belief that all bad
things happen in threes, the 616 Strange had
to put a stop to Sinister Strange.
After all the disappointment and hurt suffered
in her early years, it appeared as if Wanda
Maximoff had found her own ray of sunshine
in the form of Vision and the Avengers after
the events of "Age of Ultron."
But it wasn't meant to be as Thanos' power
ripped away everything that mattered to her.
The suffering this caused trapped her in a
darkness that gave rise to the Scarlet Witch,
one of the most powerful beings on Earth.
Scarlet Witch was responsible for the deaths
of nearly everyone on this list as she tried
to create her own perfect reality.
In the end, though, she realized that her
methods had turned her into the kind of monster
she despised.
Faced with what she had become, she destroyed
the Darkhold in every universe and destroyed
the ruins of Mount Wundagore, burying herself
under the rubble.
There's no guarantee that Wanda is well and
truly gone since this is the comic book movie
world and deaths are about as permanent as
rub-on tattoos.
If this was her last appearance, though, at
least she died as a hero and not the villain.
Comic book movies can be extremely cruel.
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
marked the third time that we witnessed Patrick
Stewart's Charles Xavier die onscreen.
First, we watched him be vaporized by Jean
Grey in "X-Men: The Last Stand," then he made
us all bawl our eyes out as he met his demise
in "Logan," and now this?
Professor X is quickly becoming the Sean Bean
of superhero films.
Much like his other portrayals, Xavier was
prepared to die for what he believed in "The
Multiverse of Madness."
While the rest of the Illuminati wanted to
stop the Scarlet Witch through the threat
of violence.
Charles tried to reach out to Wanda through
her mind and reason with the troubled magic
user.
What he found was the real Wanda trapped away
in her mind as the Scarlet Witch took over
her body.
Professor X was also close to liberating her
from the power of the Darkhold.
The Scarlet Witch proved to be too powerful
for him in the end and snapped his neck in
the psychic world.
Sadly, the consequences of this violent act
were fatal in the conscious world as well.
Marvel fans received a memorable MCU moment
as Lashana Lynch's Maria Rambeau appeared
as Captain Marvel, dispelling all theories
that it was Tom Cruise as the Invincible Iron
Man in the trailer footage.
However, this was Earth-838's version of the
character, not the main universe's Captain
Marvel, who is presumably still Carol Danvers.
It was a nice tribute to Maria, who was introduced
as Danvers' best friend and went on to found
the alien-intelligence agency S.W.O.R.D.
Plus, it laid an excellent foundation for
"The Marvels," as Maria's daughter, Monica,
developed cosmic powers in "WandaVision."
Unfortunately, Captain Marvel flew too close
to the sun in "The Multiverse of Madness"
as Scarlet Witch crushed her with a giant
pillar.
While Maria's powers were as impressive and
fiery as expected, she was no match for Wanda
in the battle.
Out of all of the Illuminati members, she
was the one who put up the most resistance,
but her biggest failure was the same as the
others: They underestimated just how powerful
the Scarlet Witch really was.
Sometimes, trailers spoil the biggest surprises.
"The Illuminati will see you now."
That's what happened in the case of "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness."
Many fans predicted the arrival of Captain
Carter in the movie, thanks to one of the
final trailers that showed off the iconic
shield.
It wasn't the first time that we saw Peggy
Carter as the super-soldier, as she flung
the mighty shield in "What If... ?" as well.
That said, there was something special about
seeing Hayley Atwell's Captain Carter in live-action.
While Earth-838's Cap put up a valiant fight
against Scarlet Witch and even uttered the
unforgettable "I can do this all day" phrase,
the shield ended up being her downfall.
It worked well as a weapon when Cap flung
it around and used it to bounce off enemies
and walls, but it also demonstrated how dangerous
it could be if it wasn't caught on time.
Let's put it this way: After this incident,
there were two Caps in Earth-838 and neither
of them was much for fighting.
The only good news is Captain Carter will
still show up in future episodes of "What If... ?"
It finally happened!
The casting that every MCU fan demanded: "The
Office" star John Krasinski as Reed Richards.
For years, Fantastic Four fans have wondered
when and how Marvel's First Family would debut
in the shared cinematic universe, and the
answer arrived emphatically in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
The stretchy superhero appeared as part of
the Illuminati and did his best to halt Scarlet
Witch in her tracks, but Wanda turned Mister
Fantastic into her own personal Play-Doh and
ended his brief appearance in the movie.
Expectedly, many fans are wondering if this
will be a one-and-done deal for Krasinski's
Richards in the MCU.
Considering how vocal the people have been
about this casting in the past and how well-received
it was by the general audience, it would feel
like a missed opportunity if Marvel Studios
didn't introduce Krasinski as Earth-616's
Mister Fantastic as well.
The only question is, who will be making up
the remaining members of the Fantastic Four?
Maybe his wife, Emily Blunt, might suit up
as Susan Storm, even if she claims to not
be interested in superhero movies.
"Come find me when you wake u-"
While ABC's "Inhumans" series was far from
a resounding success and constantly cited
as one of the MCU's biggest misses, Anson
Mount's Black Bolt received a chance at redemption
in "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness."
Introduced in a comics-accurate costume and
as a member of the Illuminati, he only showed
up for a brief moment in the film.
However, it was arguably a much better depiction
of the character than the first time we met
the big shot of Attilan in the 2017 television
show.
While fans found out how destructive a whisper
from Black Bolt can be and Reed Richards threatened
to unleash him on Scarlet Witch if she didn't
back down, the Inhuman's death quickly became
an online meme after the film's release.
Wanda magically stitched up Black Bolt's mouth,
causing him to panic, make the slightest of
peeps, and blow up his own head.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.